j'ai une bonne nouvelle Lady en je
savais pas qu'on la croyait morte je lui
confié la mission
d'éliminer est de santerement et
territoriement ceèm dans la
ré votre mission c'est de localiser les
et de finir
tra
pasreliquellementent pte la forme et
pour ce qui est de la fille elle
travaille pour une agence
américaine trouvez c'est votre
priorité c'est un trur qui permet de
repérer
Yuki j'ai perdu le contact avec mon
équipe je dois les retrouver si tenté
qu'il soit encore en vie on y va je sais
même pas comment on s'en sert vous
faites
ça
je croyais pas que ce serait aussi
facile ils ont pas beaucoup d'hommes en
fait puisse Dieu bénir l'état sacré
d'Aragon je l' en Lig
de c'est fait
non